welcome everyone uh to the first of our
two-part webinar series on the 2022
midterm elections sponsored by Yale's
Institution for social and policy
studies
um which is known as isps uh my name is
Alan Gerber I'm a professor at Yale in
the department of political science and
director of isps and today I'm very
excited to share with you the insights
of our expert panel and I'll be
introducing them shortly
um so first I just want to encourage you
there's a a good amount of time in the
webinar for question and answer and so
please send questions for the panel at
any time through the Q a button at the
bottom of your Zoom screen
and so and please try we're going to try
and read the questions that you ask to
capture your own voice and so we'll be
able to do that if you keep the
questions uh brief
uh and in a form that that's easy for us
to to feel to our to our colleagues on
the panel and I just want to also say
that today's event is being recorded and
we'll be posting the link of the video
as soon as possible
and then also for those of you who are
on Twitter our handle is at isps Yale
and you can also use the hashtag isps
midterms 2022.
I want to begin by thanking the staff uh
the people in the Yale Community who
really make um make all the events that
we do here at highest PS possible I want
to give special thanks to Pam green Rick
Harrison Lamour Pierre and hero wishart
for all they do to help isps fulfill its
research and education mission
and then the rhythm of the event tonight
will be this the panelists will speak
for five to seven minutes
um when they're finished we're gonna
have a discussion among the panelists uh
for maybe 20 minutes or so and then
that'll be followed by
um a question and answer period uh where
the questions that you've been
um uh uh sending us during the
um during the panel phase will be uh
will be fielded to the to the panelists
and with that I I just want to introduce
today's panel uh who will be presenting
in alphabetical order
so first uh Mophie Arena oh these are
going to be brief introductions because
I just want to leave as much time as
possible for the presentations
discussion and question and answer so
and and these are very distinguished
people so it could go on for a while if
I I went through the whole whole thing
okay so MO fiorina is a professor at
Stanford he's the wet family professor
of political science author of many
books and the member of many
distinguished academic societies
including the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences and the National Academy of
Sciences
Josh Cala is our second presenter Josh
is the assistant is an assistant
professor of political science at Yale
uh and is also in the department of
statistics and data science
and a reverend fellow by SPS uh he works
on political persuasion Prejudice
reduction decision making among voters
and political Elites and he's won a new
number of awards to recognize the
scholarship including the Lemur
Rosenthal prize for open social science
Mike pothauser is the former political
director of the AFL-CIO he's also the
founding chair of the analyst Institute
and one of the most important
institutional actors in Progressive
politics over the past few decades
um were extremely privileged to have him
joining us today
and then finally Lynn vavrick
Lynn is the Marvin hoffenberg professor
of American politics and public policy
at UCLA
Lynn has been a Pioneer in many areas in
American political Behavior Uh recently
in 2020 she led the nationscape election
project the largest study of
presidential elections ever fielded in
the United States she's also the
recipient of numerous Awards and the
author of numerous books her Awards
include the Andrew Carnegie prize in the
humanities and social sciences and with
that let me turn it over to our
panelists who will speak in alphabetical
order
okay well our instructions Professor
Gerber asked us not to make more than
two or three arguments I'll do better
than that I'm not going to make any
arguments I'll give you one not so
courageous guest and the reason for that
is normally after every election there
is a narrative that takes hold about
what happened and uh often The Narrative
is wrong when we actually do our
analyzes but at least you have something
to argue against in this election there
are just any number of competing
narratives out there uh the election
depending on who you talked to was about
abortion it was about election denying
or is about January 6th and a threat to
democracy and the critical groups were
Independents or young people or Suburban
residents or women or young women or
young college educated women and I'm not
going to go to any of these places I
think we have some real data gurus on
the program here and I'll uh I'll let
them let them have all those kinds of
questions after the 2020 election which
was disappointing for the the Democrats
or in the house not with presidency
obviously but in the house they lost 13
seats surprisingly and their margin was
only I believe nine and virtually every
political scientist in the country said
after the election the next day they're
going to lose the house in the next
election 2022. and let me start sharing
my screen here
maybe you've probably all heard this
generalization but if you've never
actually seen the numbers this is a
chart of midterm losses from the Civil
War on
1900 1902 doesn't really count there the
size of the house was increased and
everybody gained seats although the
incumbent party didn't get as many as
the others and basically one election
the New Deal and then not until Newt
Gingrich doubled out on the Monica
Lewinsky scandal in 1998 in the
aftermath of 2000 2001 terrorist attacks
did anybody ever any come at party gain
seats you can see the game is played
below the line there the only question
is how many seats you lose
now why is it always always below the
line well there are a number of theories
out there but I basically think it's the
idea of a thermostatic electorate is
what uh is is what explains it that
neither party has a majority of the
country and to win an election you
basically have to uh appeal to middle of
the rotors unaffiliated moderates Etc
but then you govern uh basically
according to the dictates of your base
and a certain number of people who voted
for you in the previous election decide
that's not what they wanted and here's
an example this is Barack Obama in
November 2008 uh the country was about
evenly split in one of the elected a
moderate or a liberal by having watched
uh cap and trade medical care ObamaCare
Etc about a quarter of the people who
thought he was a moderate decided a year
later no they elected a liberal and the
schlacking occurred after that political
scientists and developed forecasting
models to predict the seat losses
they're basically models that predict
statistical models based on economic
conditions presidential approval sucks
up everything other than the economy in
a variance like are we at War their War
casualties how many seats do you have
exposed beyond your long-term average
how long have you been in office and so
forth and those models sometimes work
quite well in 2020 for example the
average of the models was exactly on now
in 2022 those kind of models are
predicting unbelievable figures uh Seth
mascot would continually update these
and he was always getting figures like
60 seats and he of course didn't believe
that no one else did Jim Campbell was
one of the fewer forecasters who was
willing to go public and he said about
40 seats I checked with some of the
other forecasters informally and
basically they were reluctant to uh to
go public because the model simply uh
simply making predictions outside what
was expected
I think like many of the other panelists
we had to give various talks in my
pre-election prediction to the Stanford
newspaper and other venues was I'd be
very shocked if anything other than
there's something between 49 to 51 seats
for either party occurred in the Senate
and certainly no more than 30 seats in
the House 20 to 30 seats and the reason
for the caution
um obviously one or fewer marginal seats
fewer seats in the danger zone after the
last redistricting a second Republicans
already hold a lot of seats I didn't see
a lot of discussion of this you know run
up to the election in 1994 the
Republican wave of 54 seats in 2010 the
Democratic shellacking UH 60 degree
seats in 2022 they had three dozen more
seats going in so it was really unlikely
that they were going to have anything
like a 40 to 50 seats gain which is what
Kevin McCarthy said the third thing was
of course jobs and several of the
forecasters I talked to said simply they
they just simply didn't know how to take
account of that in their uh in their
models and uh frankly you always have to
call it a Republican primary voters just
to go back on some of the golden oldies
from the past in 2010 Christine
O'Donnell had to run commercials denying
and she was a witch
2012 we had a number of comments about
rape that uh struck people with some
beyond the mainstream
the uh the Republican candidate who ran
against spamberger in Virginia actually
got caught in this argument this year
she sort of sets the danger but she uh
she basically in one one campaign in
appearance she actually
agreed with this and uh is pondered her
the rest of the campaign the all-time
favorite I think was this one
these are of course senate elections and
uh we had a few candidates who were
interested McConnell said not high
quality this time I wasn't sure that
actually go to the house but we did have
some real uh real sort of surprising
candidates in the house races as well so
in some Republicans were likely to win a
house majority not as big as conditions
suggest Senate majority was uncertain in
the end uh they gained only nine seats
in the house they gained only two
governorships and they lost a senate
seat and the story basically is the
independence didn't deliver for the
Republicans when you look back over time
Independence sort of determined the size
of these midterm losses here's the the
Reagan
Era here here's the Republican wave in
94. here's the Democratic something
something in the Republic of thumping in
26 and they were kind of shocking 2014
2018. the independence actually voted
two or three percent they're all maybe
four according to samples for the
Democrats this time so it was a
Independence didn't it had a very close
margin it actually went for the
Democrats
and uh the last few elections have not
been kind to the idea of new Democratic
majority of the emerging Democratic
majority uh people have put together
these uh these from the exit polls and
the eight people uh African-Americans
continue to defect to some extent uh
Hispanics defect working class Suburban
old people young people on the other
hand were Democratic I I really like
read to share his Blog the liberal
Patriot he's a bit pessimistic on these
things he likes to try to find the dark
lining in every Silver Cloud but his
last Vlog the other day he's pointing
out all the disadvantages that the
Democrats face even though they didn't
find in the election like on immigration
the Border there are 24 points down
Republicans crime 20 economy and
abortion 20 or excuse me economy 20 that
should be inflation abortion rights
they're up a little of course in climate
change which is not an important issue
to most people and then of course on
Traditional Values again the Democrats
or to dispatch on these things so he
sees dangers ahead no matter what uh how
how they manage to escape Oblivion in
the last election and my my guess is
based on all this is that
um in general everything mattered
everything sort of added up to the
perception that the Republicans were too
extreme beyond the mainstream it was a
little bit of all the things there was a
um a nice third wave pre-auction survey
in which people were asked to place the
parties on the ideological spectrum and
what was interesting is they actually
judged the
judge the parties to be equal not
actually because the judge the
Democratic party be more extreme
ideologically the Republican party but
when asked about the current candidates
this year know they felt the Republicans
had nominated more extreme candidates
this year so I'll end with that and
along my fellow panelists to flush it on
okay so um I think Mo and I as I was
saying we did not coordinate in what we
were talking about but really similar
questions and also similar answers
um but I think one question I have
coming out of this election is did the
Republicans underperform in 2022 and in
order to answer that question we need to
have some model as to how well the
Republicans should have performed in
2022 and one nice model out there there
many of these predictive models but one
nice one is from our Yale colleague Ray
fair in the economics department where
he talks about these different
um pushes and polls for for or against
the incumbent party so based on the fact
that there's a democratic incumbent and
there's some both bias against the White
House that thermostatic public opinion
that Mo was talking about cancel out by
some and come and see a fact but also
the economy was both bad with negative
very high inflation but also is good
with high GDP growth all of this when
you put this all together and Ray Fair's
model means that based on past election
results we should have expected the
Republican vote share in this election
should be about 53.4 percent and what we
ended up seeing at least as of November
23rd is that the actual Republican vote
sharing this election was about 51.6
percent so this means that Republicans
underperformed relative to these
historic models based on the uh The
Economy based on incumbency based on how
many seats they're holding in the past
Republicans seem to underperform by
about two percentage points so so it
does seem like Republicans based on what
we have known in the past but based on
what we've seen from past elections
should have done better than they end up
doing this past November so then the
obvious question to ask next is is why
and here I don't think we have very
solid answers but there's some political
science evidence that we can point to
just to suggest why it is that
Republicans might have underperformed
that Democrats might have overperformed
and one piece of evidence we see is that
Democrats raised and spent more money
than Republicans this election so in U.S
House races
um Democrats spent about 408 million
dollars on TV ads while Republican
candidates and Affiliated groups spent
about 380 million dollars on their TV
ads and Lynn vavrick who's speaking
later along with a few colleagues John
sizing and Chris warshaw have a really
nice recent paper in the American
Political Science review
showing that when one party has an
advertising advantage over another party
this leads to an electoral impact there
is a benefit to spending more ads than
the other side
um it's a pretty significant effect
especially in down ballot races like the
House of Representatives where Democrats
outperformed what these models would
predict so I think one explanation as to
why Republicans underperformed is they
might have just spent less money than
the Democratic Party
another explanation which Mo talked a
little bit about is about extremism
about how Republican primaries
voted for
um for candidates who were just more
extreme less high quality than who the
Democrats went for and again there's
really nice work
um in political science by Andy hall now
at Stanford for example who looks at
what happens when more extreme
candidates win primary elections is
there an electoral penalty and one model
of the world might say no there is no
electoral penalty that all that matters
in American politics today is whether
you have a d or an R next to your name
Democrats but for Democrats Republicans
vote for Republicans there are very very
few Independents and all that matters is
the partisanship of who's running in
that they're the extremism of the
individual candidates does not matter
and what Andy finds in this paper is
that view is is wrong that individual
candidates do in fact matter more
extreme candidates are punished when it
comes to the general election and there
does seem to be some evidence from this
and in the most recent election uh the
New York Times did a really nice
analysis where they looked at uh U.S
House races where there was a
quote-unquote mega Republican who won
the primary election and ran in the
general compared to all other uh
Republican races and what you see when
you just look at how these Maga versus
non-maga Republicans did in 2022
relative to 2020 is that the
the typical Republican the Chamber of
Commerce Republican they actually did
much better in 2022 than they did in
2020 by about six points the issue for
the Republican party is that those Mega
Republicans did much worse in 2022
relative to the 2020 Benchmark they
actually performed about half a point
worse so this really seems to suggest
that who the Republicans ran in these
elections might have been a contributing
factor for the underperformance of the
Republican Party
and then the third I think obvious
point but I think a really open point is
this backlash overturning Rogue Way the
the Dodge decision and here I I actually
haven't seen any I think convincing
evidence showing how or why to what
extent the dogs really matter I think it
it very likely did
um but I think just an open question I
would love if the other panelists have
any thoughts on this is what data would
actually test whether or not or how
would we know whether or not jobs
mattered
um because it likely did but it would be
nice to be able to triangulate with some
data around that
um but that's it for me and I'll turn it
over to Mike podhurser thanks Josh
um I'm actually going to start in a
different place than I thought because
of how the previous panelists started
um the before getting to my presentation
and as a couple I know Alan knows and
Josh knows her and maybe event who've
like been getting some of my stuff for
the last couple years I thought the
Democrats actually could hold the house
this year and that I went through sort
of two long years of eye rolling at me
um and that's because I think what ended
up happening was that Republicans over
performed from a very different
perspective than the modeling we just
heard right if you
um in November 2008 right after Barack
Obama won the election had been put in a
medically induced coma and then revived
now and we're told that in 2020 Donald
Trump had been president lost the
election staged a violent coup attempt
and then the Republican party instead of
distancing itself from him actually
tripled down on him that the result was
that they actually took the House
Representatives right it was your head
would explode
um and I think sometimes we'd pay for
too much attention to the
um the sort of to the data in a very
sort of myopic way and not understand
that we're in a different political time
since 2016. and that's what I'm going to
talk about
um so
um as folks were saying the result was
not with the models suggested was going
to happen it's not what people who were
following it said were going to happen
and it isn't just that it didn't happen
it happened it didn't happen in a
spectacular way
since the Voting Rights Act these were
the seven uh midterms in which the
president was underwater and all the
other things are sort of going wrong
there's only one where the party picks
up Governor State Legislative Chambers
has such a small loss it's completely a
historical
um and if you even drill down a little
bit more right it's as you just heard
nine seats lost despite all those
fundamentals plus Rising prices crime
all of that double-digit losses if you
go even further think about this in
particular Gretchen Whitmer and Tony
Evers one re-election by more that in
the red election than they won in the
Blue Wave right and going back again to
post uh the ra but that's not ever
happened
um Democrats netting State Legislative
Chambers that's never happened
or Democratic senators were elected or
re-elected from swing States
um this this cycle only three total in
any midterm since 1994 have been able to
do that against their president's party
it it it's an astonishingly different
political environment
and I think part of the reason that
people are we don't have a handle on it
is because of the explanations we get
for how this happened really don't match
the the data or the moment that they're
kind of procrustian explanation swing
voters Independents all of that and I
don't have a obviously a conclusive
answer but want to offer
um a few observations about a different
way to think about it right so if
proquestion right is the idea is that
you
um to make sure that your guest gets the
bed comfortably just cut off what
doesn't fit right and what our analysis
of Elections since Trump had been doing
is really cutting off the effect of
differential partisan turnout the local
political context as opposed to race by
race analysis and what the media is
saying in each of these markets is we
really told me the media that gets to
really conclusively say what's true and
what's not
and the after 2016 right the turnout
just became something it never was right
turnout went up by almost 14 points in
2018 twice as much as it ever had since
reconstruction which was twice as much
as it had ever gone before that we're
just in a different turnout era and so
almost all the analysis we've read or
heard about is about the roughly 11
million people who might be called swing
voters or Independents and the
electorate and nothing about the 45
million people who voted in 2020 but
stayed home this time right which is a
very different situation from historic
midterms and historic midterms about
three quarters of the electorate or more
were four or four voters and now that's
down to just under 50 percent right
there's just a big new pool of Voters
and no one's paying attention to them
and that's where
um these shifts are happening right so
the thing I want to put out is that I
don't think that this was a Red Mist I
think we actually had two midterms in
the country we had one midterm
um that was the red wave that all those
models were predicting and I shouldn't
say way the blue undertow
um and so the metric that I'm going to
use in these couple slides is
presidential swing in each of the
districts the difference between what
the Democrat got and what Biden got two
years ago limiting it to the 150 closest
races just so it's comparable across
regions and uh time periods and because
that 64-day and beyond that it really
doesn't matter much right so the swing
in those 150 districts in 2018 was seven
points away from Republicans and four
points away from Democrats and that's
the mental model that people have
but if you split the country into one
country which is
um the what I'm calling the Maga war
zone which are the you know the the the
Electoral College places where things
are really Fierce and the rest of the
country you see that really there was no
difference between the swing
um that Trump endured and the swing the
Democrats endured in that part of the
country but in the nagawar zone
Democrats did barely less well than
Biden did two years ago and because I
would argue people voters in those
States understood this is Playing for
Keeps real Naga no Maga
um and the other way of sort of looking
at it in terms of the modeling was that
I did uh 538 vinyl Deluxe which has like
all the things they can throw into it
and Democrats overperformed the estimate
for them by 4.4 points in this mega war
zone and they 538 you know came as close
to nailing the rest of the districts as
you can imagine
um and so the last thing is just to say
that this idea of missing voters it's
the
the and I'm sure we'll come back to
questions but the dynamic that I think
now there was clearly switching and
stuff like that but the dynamic is that
turnout went up among Democrats in that
mega war zone turnout among Republicans
was about the same in in both areas uh
and one of the things that this helps
explain that the bad candidate
um all the other kinds of that you know
independent voter explanations doesn't
explain is why if you have an
independent for example who comes out
and says mastriano oh my God I can't
vote for them
did that person who other than that were
Pro were postulating would have been a
thermostatic voter give Democrats big
down ballot gains in the state how did
they flip the two Chambers in Michigan
right because it is because the the Big
Driver was that they were just more
Democrats and it didn't matter whether
the Republican was a denier not just
having decided to come out and vote was
What mattered and I'll stop there
because that's my time sorry
thanks Mike
I will kind of pick up a whole bunch of
those threads and see if we can
tell a little bit of a broader story
about what is
um happening in American politics at
this moment in time and what it might
mean for the future and so the stuff
that I'm going to talk about here in the
next
um five or six minutes comes from a book
that I've just written called The Bitter
End with my colleague at UCLA Chris
tosanovich and my longtime co-author
John sides who is at Vanderbilt and our
answer to this question about what just
happened in the midterms and what is
happening in American politics more
generally turns on this idea of
calcification
and calcification sounds a lot like
polarization but it is not just
polarization
um I like to say it's polarization plus
and the plus is uh really important so
there are four components of
polarization and I'll tell you what they
are briefly two of them are a long time
in the making and two of them are more
recent so the first two are sort of
long-term tectonic shifts that have
taken time and the last two you can
think of as little earthquakes shocks
that have happened recently
the first two sound a lot like
polarization so an increasing
homogeneity within each of the parties
so people who call themselves Democrats
are more alike than they've ever been on
issues on ideology possibly even on
characteristics same thing for
republicans
the second thing is an increasing
distance between the two parties
something that we've seen happen in
Congress for a long time but is now
happening in the electorate on average
people's attitudes about policies in the
electorate are very far apart when you
sort them by political party
the more recent things include a change
in the set of issues that we're fighting
over so the importance of identity
inflected issues things that turn on
Race ethnicity religion gender so that
would be things like abortion
immigration the Muslim ban separating
children at the border all of those
kinds of person-based issues have become
the thing that is contested politically
as opposed to the New Deal type of
political contestation that defined most
of politics in our lifetimes so the role
in size of government the tax rate
whether small businesses should be taxed
higher or lower whether low-income
families should be taxed higher or lower
Joe the plumber is the classic example
if everybody remembers him from the 2008
presidential campaign we don't fight
we're not fighting over those things
anymore so the dimension of conflict has
shifted but that's
something that has taken about a decade
that's the more recent the first two
things are multiple decades since the
60s the Civil Rights and Voting Rights
Act these last two things are within the
last decade the final thing is partisan
parity within the electorate so a rough
balance between people calling
themselves Democrats and people calling
themselves Republicans right now in the
electorate it's not a perfect balance
but it's closer than it's been in the
last 70 or 80 years those four things
matched up together lead us to this
state of politics that we saw we call
calcification and just like in the human
body calcification makes things stiff
and rigid why because the stakes of
winning elections are very high why
because the other side is farther away
than ever
and because of the partisan parody
Victory is always Within Reach for both
sides and we're fighting over these
extremely divisive person-based issues
and so when you mash all those things up
together it becomes very difficult for
voters say whose party nominated a
candidate who they don't think are high
quality becomes very difficult for those
voters to say oh well okay in this
particular election I'm going to cross
over and vote for the other side because
I don't love the person my party
nominated we're talking about a couple
of points on the tax rate or
um you know whether government should
really be involved in health care and
maybe you can cross over but when you're
saying I don't think we should be
separating children from their families
at the border I don't love the person my
party's nominated but you know what I'm
going to vote for the person who wants
to separate the children it's a
completely different kind of stretching
of your party affiliation to vote for
the other side and so the this context
has produced this state of stickiness
that we call calcification
so I want to show you just a couple of
the consequences of calcification the
first is that voters have observed these
differences and appreciate them between
the parties very different worlds on
offer on these identity inflected things
between Republicans and Democrats and
voters know it so here I'm showing you
time on the horizontal axis and the
share of people on the vertical axis who
say they have seen important differences
between the two political parties in
1952 you can see for reasons that
everybody can figure out only one out of
two Americans thinks there are important
differences between the two parties but
today that number is 90 percent so nine
out of 10 Americans think the two
parties have important differences so
the first piece of evidence that the
state of politics today is different for
voters than it has been at any previous
point over the last several decades
decades here's another implication of
calcification the emotional reaction to
political parties here we're asking
people to rate their party and the other
party on a zero to 100 scale that's like
a thermometer 100 is very cold you don't
like them sorry zero is very cold you
don't like them a hundred is hot you do
like them 50 is neutral take it or leave
it so people have always liked their own
party putting it up here in the 19 or
sorry in the 70 rating range from 1978
to the present day
but they like the opposite party a lot
less than they used to we used to have
neutral feelings about the out party and
now you can see we're down here at 19.
people really dislike the opposite party
that emotional reaction can be based on
a lot of things but certainly a
component is the figure I showed you
just a minute ago that people perceive
important differences in the kind of
world that each of these parties want to
create and they don't like the world
that the out party wants to create
another consequence of calcification is
something that you've heard a couple of
the other panelists talk about that
elections are becoming tighter there's
less swing and so very quickly I'm just
showing you here the two-party vote
share for the Democrats between 08 and
12 between 12 and 16 and then between 16
and 20. each dot is a state and this
diagonal 45 degree line would be where
the dots would all be if the Democratic
party got the same share of the vote in
the 08 election for example and the 12
election so you can quickly see the dots
are not on the line between 08 and 12
the dots are below the line indicating
that in every state Obama did worse than
12 than he did in 08 easy to understand
he gets a big boost and wins in a
landslide because of the global
financial crisis and then in 2012 some
of those voters peel off this one's a
little more complicated Hillary Clinton
picking up votes relative to Obama in
States like California Arizona and Texas
but losing them in States like Ohio
Pennsylvania and Iowa this is a
reshuffling of the States into a new
equilibrium that you can see persisting
between 2016 and 2020. how do you see
that because all of these dots are very
close to the line and they are almost on
the line this tells us that the 2020
election was almost a replay of the 2016
presidential election very few people
there could be you know Mike just talked
about turnout that's really important
here there could be different people
turning out in these elections but the
outcome of these elections state by
state is very close 16 to 20. you can
see it at the county level as well here
we're showing you over time the average
county level swing from the last
election to the one that is indicated on
the horizontal axis some of the swings
have been very big 20 point average
County swings in presidential election
outcomes in the 60s and 70s
but you can see over time this County
swing is going down in 2020 it's the
smallest value it has ever been it's
about three percentage points that's
calcification everything is more the
same and looks a lot like the last time
relative to what we've seen in the past
and then finally just to wrap up what
about what just happened
here's the Georgia runoff oh sorry
didn't mean to didn't mean to to hit
that button okay here's 2021 on the left
and 2022 on the right and if you just
stare at this and look at it you can you
will be able to see that they're very
similar
um a lot of red at the top in both
places blew around the urban areas and
the college campuses
um almost everywhere except for the
right hand part of the state here which
became a little redder in 2022 it looks
very similar that's calcification in
this runoff election just in Georgia
and then finally another sense of like
the difference between the two parties
is just to look at a couple counties so
here's a red County just outside of
Atlanta okay and 70 30 roughly for
Walker an adjacent County right here
near Atlanta
80 20 for Warnock these are people
living in the suburbs of Atlanta they're
roughly living the same kinds of lives
but they're living in very different
places and they know it and they
appreciate it and all of this is leading
to this sense of being stuck
um don't want the world that the other
side is offering and the idea that
calcification because the stakes of
elections are so high the other side is
far away
um has left us at a point where very
little is going to change these
elections are going to be very close
going forward and that means that
literally anything could be flipping
them calcification doesn't mean the same
side always wins it means the elections
are going to be razor thin all those
things Mike just talked about all the
things that Josh and Moe talked about
out are going to be swinging these
elections
um and the era of the blowout is
probably gone
how long is it going to last
um my guess is probably the rest of my
lifetime but a new dimension of conflict
is what we need in order to shift us out
of this current state
um and we could spend a lot of time
thinking about exactly what that is
um and I'll end there and I think we're
all going to come back on is that right
Alan
yes yes it is Lynn yes it is okay
um terrific so let's uh take a few
seconds for the panel to reassemble
um while we're doing that let me um uh
again urge our audience members to uh to
formulate and share their questions in
the the Q a
um there are there are some questions
now and where um I'd be we're very
interested in knowing what your
questions are so we can
um so the panelists can address those
questions so let me just start by um by
asking the panelists these were for I
think very interesting and and uh and
and fairly different
um presentations uh why don't one of the
great things about a panel is uh you get
to actually react and talk to your
fellow uh panelists
um does anyone just want to start with
um and I hope we'll be able to do this
for a few minutes let's see if this this
this this actually works do you have
question a question you'd like to ask or
comment you'd like to make
um about something that one of your
fellow panelists
[Music]
presented on either one of their
observations or conclusions or something
like that and uh
I see great eagerness among
um
please just go right ahead okay
um so um hi Mo uh you um you mentioned
the swing voters and that we've always
known that campaigns were playing to
these people who were the swing in the
middle and I wondered if you thought
that that
um that share of the electorate has
gotten smaller so obviously the margin
is still really important
um but you know maybe if we used to have
swing voters that were this much now
it's this much I wonder can you say a
little bit about how you think of that
sure um am I on okay the uh
yeah I think it has gotten smaller but
no less important in fact more important
that what you talked about earlier the
parody of the parties it doesn't matter
if if the swing voters are two percent
if the parties are divided 49.49 they
still determine the election so
essentially you know it doesn't they
don't have to be a huge quantity to
decide an election not I do take issue
with this uh this belief among
journalists and among younger political
scientists that nearly all leaning
Independence are in fact cause of
partisans and I have evidence against
that in my last book uh nobody seems to
have read that chapter I can't remember
but anyway
um because they switched from election
to election the same person who says I'm
leaning independent and one election
tells you I'm leaning I'm a leading
Democrat in one election tells him when
he Republican in the next election so
their party ideas their meaning is
following their vote decision rather
than vice versa but yeah I think in an
era of close party competition the
independence whatever their size the
middle ground I mean and by the way the
Independents are not all principal
centrists they're they're just they're
they're moderates there are people who
are disengaged in politics there are
cross-pressure people who don't really
like either party they're clueless
people they're this but the thing they
have in common is they're volatile that
the particular campaign and candidates
can make them change their votes from
election election so they are they're in
the driver's seat basically in this era
yeah I can chat should be you know the
independent point for a minute
um and get something I sort of tried to
wave at and what I was saying is that I
think that somebody noticed that we
really limited our imagination of how
politics happens to what we can see in
polls
and so on the independent point right I
think one of the things we saw this time
around and part of what I was trying to
get at in the difference between living
in a mega war zone State and not is that
the people around you have a very
different feeling about what's at stake
in the election right and so if you were
in Georgia you understood that even if
you thought Herschel Walker was the
biggest idiot in the world that you
didn't want Chuck Schumer to be majority
leader and you knew exactly what you
were voting on it wasn't about issues it
wasn't about any of those things
on the other hand I am as convinced this
you can be about this stuff that there
were a lot of folks who voted for Biden
in California and New York who did not
understand that by staying home they
were making Kevin McCarthy speaker
because no one was talking about it no
one was saying that there was this
National Dimension to the election in
that kind of hot house way it was in the
other states and you're just not going
to see that on a poll right and but that
is actually how the world works I mean
that's how you know like what you see in
your social networks what people are
talking about right and so I think that
that's another part of the story that
gets left out on Independence right I
think what you were saying is right
they're the clueless people right I mean
if you're living in this country and
don't understand what's up right then
you're going to swing back and forth but
if you're in that like Madison or like
in Wisconsin and you're you know you go
to diner for breakfast every morning
you're sitting in the big table in the
middle you know who you're supposed to
vote for right and if you're in a
different place where it isn't like
acute politics you don't and so you're
like wagging back and forth and I think
there are lots of things like that that
we don't take into the analysis and
story about why we get the results we do
if I can follow up on with Mike
um so there's all this talk of the
nationalization of American politics
with the demise of local media and
people relying more on National sources
with people you know tuning into
National social media rather than local
sense people knowing less about their
National their local candidates even as
they know more about the differences
between the national parties as Lynn was
sharing if it's true that there's this
nationalization of American politics
why does it matter if you're an
independent voter in
California or an independent voter in
Georgia or do you think
we as political scientists might be
overstating the case of this
nationalization of American politics
the I think that what I should say is
that it's not it's it's it's sensitive
to the the context in the moment right
that the the during the you know Trump
Administration years right you could not
hide anywhere and not hear about all
this stuff right and in the last two
years if you're not living in one of
these states where they're doing scam
audits or you know doing lots of high
visibility things you can if and you're
not really clued in then you kind of
think things have gone back to normal
and so I don't think you can say there's
like one way to understand independent
voters in every state at all times right
so in some sense Biden being boring has
brought back this less of a national
Dimension that exists yeah no I think
that that that's been a big problem for
the first year and a half was that he
was really going against the only
motivation that would get people to do
what they ended up doing
okay um any other follow-ups on that
line of of discussion one question I I
was wondering about is this discussion
was going on was is there an implication
of the calcification ideas or that
candidate quality would be less
important
um and if so is is that is that what
you're predicting that we'll see because
it it did seem like some of the
arguments Josh and and mo might have
made as well was that and I think I
think it's anecdotal evidence I haven't
seen I've seen a little bit of analysis
was that
um the you know the the quote-unquote
candidate quality problem really really
did manifest itself
um uh and you know you can see it in the
difference between up and down ballot
voting and some of these some of these
cases among other other indicators
for sure Ohio and Pennsylvania are great
examples of that
um and uh yeah I would I would say that
um
you know I'm never going to say that
candidate quality is irrelevant that's
true
um and
um I I think that what we're saying is
that
um
take the argument that Mo made a minute
ago about those swing voters being
critically important now and you know
what's swinging them all I think of
these swing voters as being they're
trying to speak a language and their
dictionary is a little broken right
they're trying to purchase they're
trying to participate in politics but
like they just they don't pay attention
they don't watch the news they don't
understand the issues they don't really
care about very much and so and that is
I know that that really sounds like
disparaging and I didn't mean it to
sound that way but
um they're trying to communicate their
dictionary is a little broken so things
like candidate quality that really means
a lot
um because it's easy to understand it's
accessible and so I think that um we
wouldn't say that it's it you know it
may be affecting fewer people than it
has in the past but it may be pivotal as
ever yeah actually I'm going to jump on
the candidate quality thing because I
think this is really needs to be
differentiated
candidate quality absolutely matters for
governor
right the because it doesn't have this
National implication that's how you get
Hogan or Baker or something like that by
people who are voting 70 30 Democratic
nationally so you know if you ha and in
I can't even remember the guy in
Maryland where I live who's like the
wacko Maga
um Republican right we've got about
seven votes this time right I mean
that's candidate quality it's the
gubernatorial level
and so I think if we're talking
candidate quality we really should just
limit it there are two different
questions the other thing though and
this is where I think sometimes when we
because we are like grounded in pulse
and attitudes rather than if you do
Focus if you go to focus groups or talk
to voters and all that it's not that
people just have different attitudes
about policies it's that we've evolved
different ways of living in the country
and so it isn't just about you know is
this person agreeing with me but could I
lose the right to an abortion right like
in my life right that's a it's a
different thing
and so I think Kerry Lake offers a
really good
um counter example because if you turn
the volume off
and sorry Katie she was like one of the
best candidates
this time around she had Deep Roots and
credibility as a news anchor she came
across well it's just that people
understood what she was going to do to
the state right that's not when we think
of bad candidate quality we think of
Sharon Engel or Aiken or mastriano right
so I think it's we have to parse we have
to parse out that there's a substantive
Dimension to this in this Maga era that
is different from their bad politicians
yeah that's fair but it was I think it
was even the case I haven't looked at
this in quite a while but
um but back in the day I looked at
candidates for senate elections and but
remember correctly one of the one of the
fake outs in a sense was the um the par
the governor of the wrong party who
looked like they would be a very good
candidate for Senate
um uh and when they moved up tried to
move up from sen from Governor they
sometimes did well while they were
Governor after all but they they were
not the they they often lost
um they often weren't able to move from
being the the governor of the so
governor of Massachusetts would be an
example as you were saying they were
very good Governors they weren't going
to be able to go to Federal equivalent
level federal office for the obvious
reasons and I imagine that might even be
more more of a problem this time around
um in this era okay
um other questions uh or comments by
panelists
you know the house incumbency advantage
has declined steadily over like the last
20 or 25 years and I think it's directly
tied to the party differences we're
talked about here that in an era when
basically it doesn't matter which
Republican you elect it's going to vote
the same way as any other Republican and
the Committees are centralized and under
the leadership of the leadership so it's
simply a question of do you want Mitch
McConnell or Chuck Schumer well in the
house I mean do you want uh Nancy policy
or Kevin McCarthy uh to be the the
speaker and um and so I think that's why
people are simply not paying nearly as
much attention to who their house
incumbents are as they were 20 25 years
ago
other other thoughts
um just one one other question just
because I it's such such an interesting
group of of Scholars and uh and
observers of American politics
um just and I think we'll probably end
up going when we go to the question and
answer right back to uh political
behavior in elections
um does anyone uh care to offer comments
about implications of their uh
assessments for governance
um for what this means for uh or for
what is the public policy uh output the
Democratic you know the implications for
democracy things like that
um so what implications what have you
what did you what is your takeaway after
this election regarding
um prospects or have you learned
anything from this election or do you
have anything you want to share
regarding your views about governance or
um or the state of our democracy
it looks bad
yeah you care well you care to elaborate
neither fiorina well I mean what what is
going what is Congress going to do
they're just revving up investigations
and we're sort of starting on the 2024
campaign right now and the Republicans
are going to obviously have a big fight
between the mega types who want to get
back at every Democrat they can think
about and they've been conducting
investigations and a wing that would
like to show they might have some
ability to cover should they get a
majority and should they win the
presidency and you know I just think and
the Democrats are going to be frustrated
not being able to get anything done so I
think two years nothing happens things
just get worse
so I think it was a complete disaster
catastrophe for governance and for like
it will people will look back on this
it's a really big loss moment if you
remember like after the second
impeachment trial the sort of Savvy
opinion and all the people who were sort
of talking about what comes next that
people wanted to move on that that if
you went after Trump or the people who
were trying to overturn the government
everyone would see it as partisan and
that you know just can't do that and but
that when the j6 hearing started it
turned out that's not what people think
right people actually want a government
that enforces the law and that in fact
over these last years when you know the
banks everybody else has been too big to
jail I think there's and we see this in
focus groups and like a lot of things
people want accountability and I think
the you know you if any of you had been
asked if the Democrats held the j6
hearing the second week of October and
they rated Mar-A-Lago whether everyone
voters would just think oh that's just
partisan politics you'd say of course
but that isn't what happened and so
what's going to happen now because
Republicans are going to do what Mo just
said is we are going to muddy this right
they are going to take what was coming
to be a consensus about the
unacceptability of what happened and
create his confusion continue the idea
that there was something illegitimate
and so like yeah there's a lot of stuff
about you know passing bills and all the
other things but we really almost had a
moment where we could get back on track
on rule of law and sort of coming
together around accountability and
that's kind of shot
I'll give a contrarian I don't know if I
believe what I'm about to say but I'll
give it a contrarian optimistic take
which is
what we've been seeing over the last
couple of years is is as Lynn showed
really good data on is that people see
differences between the two parties they
recognize that when you're voting for
Democrats you are getting Nancy Pelosi
or Chuck Schumer and that means a
certain constellation of ideas or when
you're voting for Republicans you are
voting for Kevin McCarthy and Mitch
McConnell you're getting a certain
consolation of ideas and certain
constellation policies and it means now
that voters are being guided more by
these differences these policy
differences between the parties and that
you know maybe the optimistic take is
that voters are going to get what they
want they're going to get this
policy that's reflective of who they're
voting for because they now recognize
the stakes of the policy Stakes of who
they're voting for they're no longer
voting for their local member of
Congress because
they're a good guy or whatever it may be
they're now voting for their member of
Congress because they want Nancy pelosia
because they want Kevin McCarthy they
they're they're Guided by these policy
motivations whether or not they end up
getting that
is limited by the bicameralism and all
the veto points in American politics but
I think the optimistic take on voter
behavior on individual voters as that
they're seeing these policy differences
these major differences between the
parties I think that could be
encouraging
I'll pick up on the optimism thread
because everybody always tells me that
the calcification argument is a real
bummer
um and just say that Alan like you asked
about policy and
um policy like the policies that affect
people's lives can come from places
other than Congress so gridlock in
Congress for sure don't disagree with
any of that but
the word that I would use to describe
what kinds of policy environment people
are going to be living in is just
Whiplash so
you you elect Donald Trump and maybe he
writes a bunch of executive orders
changes the world in One Direction You
elect Joe Biden he comes in undoes all
of that back in the other direction and
so a lot and they're so far apart that
for voters I think a lot of what it's
going to feel like is whiplash um it was
this it was that policies devolving down
to States there's one policy in
California there's another policy in
Ohio so it's going to be you know very
different
um over time and space and then on the
Democracy front I would say that before
the midterm elections I was worried that
we would see continued backsliding
people who lost elections would not
concede they would call on their
supporters to march on their state
capital or or some such and the fact
that we saw very little of that
um I think was a really important moment
for democracy so also an optimistic note
great
um I think this is a very interesting
topic and and I just want to give the
panelists uh who spoke early in the the
round to have the opportunity to respond
if they and to add any other comments
they want to before we move
to the um to the audience questions
seeing limited desire to do so
um why don't we move on to the questions
and let me just remind our audience just
send along questions and I I'm going to
try and read the questions that you send
along so send them along in a form that
um that is friendly friendly for that
purpose okay so let me just get started
with some of those questions
um so Quest here's a question I'd like
to give Mike a chance to spin out his
argument further if the crucial question
is how a GOP the triple down on trumpism
after January 6th still captured the
house how does a focus on turnout and a
distinction between the Maga Battlefield
and other races answer that question
yeah so I said thanks the I think the
the the framework that I'm coming at it
from is that in November 2020 as much
probably as any election ever people
understood that it was about four more
years of Maga or not and when that
happened 81 million people voted for not
four more years with Mecca which means
that in almost every race that mattered
there were more people who had voted
against Maga than there were who had
voted for it right and so to me the the
the
Naga will continue to be defeated to the
extent that
that group of Voters understands that
that's what this election is about again
and if they don't then they're not
habitual voters they just go back to not
voting
um and that's that's the problem and the
and this is where for the asymmetry and
information environments is really
undermining democracy and sort of our
our hopes right and for the people who
are living in Fox World they know every
election is existential the Democrats or
pedophiles and the devil and why they
have to sort of go out and vote and the
mainstream media and the people who are
trusted wobble on it right and when you
know over
June through mid-september when the
mainstream media was very much covering
j6 Mar-A-Lago dubs all of that you saw
this big movement towards Democrats and
the generic and all of those things
these people are being reminded what's
State and then you get the reversal
where the media says oh no people don't
care about it anymore we're going to
cover other stuff and suddenly
the air starts coming out of the balloon
right
um but my point I was just going to say
mike um yeah so I I just I I think I
just want to call uh call your attention
to one one part of the of the question
that
um the question of the differential
patterns in the Maga versus the the
non-magastates if you had about how that
fits oh yeah just that what I was saying
is that in the the matica and non or the
mega battlefields yeah the Maca Warzone
Mega Warsaw and the rest of the states
um Republican house candidates in both
places got about three quarters of the
number of votes Trump got
and in the Naga war zone Democrats got
about 70 uh 3 74 almost parody and in
the other areas only 66 percent and we
get the voter file we can parse that
more
but the the point is that there just
weren't Democrats coming out in the same
intensity in the rest of the country and
that's
um right if they're not on full alert
and although you know the one of the
things if you go back and look at 2018
or 2014 whatever you do not see these
big Regional different there's no
Regional difference between the
competitive States and the
non-competitive states and the previous
presidential race and turnout in the
midterm right it's just not sensitive to
it it's a new different phenomenon
okay great thank you very much
um okay next question uh could the
panelists address whether there are
really demographic shifts within the
country that are going to impact either
party in the future
um
okay yeah that's the that's the question
there's another parts of the question so
let's start out with demographics and
voting patterns
um
I mean I think that so this that you
know this so this I think this is in the
spirit of the Tashira
um arguments about
um so maybe maybe if you care to to sure
you'd be happy to
um
the the one of the main pieces of the
the argument of the emerging Democratic
majority is the growing number of
immigrants especially Latinos and uh
obviously it hasn't worked out that way
but
um I wrote a piece in Real Clear
Politics on this there's a really
important book by a demographer by the
name Richard Alba that Princeton or no
he's public by Princeton press and
you've probably all read this about how
we will have a non-white majority by
2045 or so and the demographers point
out that that is really that prediction
is based on a very strange way of
counting whites and non-whites and I
have slides on this which I I probably
would take me too long to try to call
pull them up but just to give an example
uh Senator Cruz is half Cuban so the
census calcium is non-white he has two
daughters his wife afraid his name but
she's she's a northern European his two
daughters who are one quarter a Cuban
they're counted by since this is
non-white if the daughters have kids in
2045 and say they're they're married
totally again no reasons or something
like that the kids who are one-eighth
Cuban will be kind that is not white
that if you it's basically a Jim Crow uh
in Reverse if you're counting if you
have anything other than non-hispanic
white in you you're a kind that is not
as a person of color and are there any
kind of reasonable way of counting
people it turns out that those
projections are way off and they go on
to show that um there's a tremendous
amount of inner marriage going on that
that in other words the kind of examples
I'm given or what's actually heard
occurring in reality and the you know
it's sort of being corrected some
circles to talk about the Great American
melting plot but it's bullying away as
much as it ever did if especially with
Hispanics and so um so neither the
bottom line is neither party should
basically base its Fate on the
expectations of mammography delivering
for you because it's not going to happen
what's going to determine elections is
issues and performance as it has in the
past
so I am really happy for this question
um the because this is something that
bothers me know and as someone who
actually tries to win elections
is that if you are running a campaign
either like whatever you're doing you're
not sitting there thinking well like how
do I do with this demographic group
you're thinking how do I get the
everybody who agrees with me to vote for
me right and you're thinking about
there's no intermediate step of whether
they're Latino or Suburban voter or
something like that right you are
building a coalition of people who agree
with different parts of what you want to
do and it's incidental right it's it's
it's
um descriptive statistics afterwards to
say that it was because they were this
or that demographic group right and
they're only two demographic groups to
me that are that are large and matter
where it's actually
operates in that way and that's why
evangelicals and African Americans where
there's such a close
um you know to a hundred percent
identity with what that demographic name
is you know but other than that it's
just going back and Counting the number
of people in each of these categories
that ended up agreeing with you and
that's why like ever after every
election people are like chasing these
like you know
um you know narrating a turtle race or
something right because that's not
what's determining what they're going to
vote for they're they're doing it on the
basis of like how you put that that
Coalition together
and further thoughts and and this
question
or comments okay seeing none actually
that's a one other thing about it yes
it's also it obviously is something that
it exercises me is that like many other
things in political analysis especially
certain uh the press and everything like
that there's just rampant ecological
fallacies right where where everybody
says oh let's pick the group they just
move this way and everybody imagines a
particular person in that group changing
their mind rather than saying well the
the group of people in that group who
voted this time is different both things
are going on right and so it's like when
you have polls that say so you know
suddenly now people care less about
issue X or they came more about issue X
you don't even know whether or not the
people who've changed their voting
partisanship or like their vote Choice
are among the group that change into
them right it's just we're we're really
sloppy about that stuff
okay
um further thoughts
all right
um next question
which issues motivated uh previously
non-voters to go to the polls and let me
um uh add to that question a little bit
thinking back say to 2018 say where we
saw a really unusual
um unusual event maybe you would say it
different times but I it was clearly
something unusual in 2018 and it uh to
what it what so what do you think is
going on uh with respect to
um the some of the breaks and the
traditional turnout patterns that that
we observed over the last
um a half decade or so
um I'll just jump in quickly
I I have not done a systematic analysis
of this but my guess is that like if I
had to bet I would bet my money on
that it isn't so much an issue as it is
a sense among people that
um their vote is going to make a
difference so the election is going to
be close
and a lot is at stake right and so
if you want me to describe issues that I
think make people feel that way they
would be these identity based issues so
in 2018 Alan you mentioned
um that's the aftermath after the 2016
election which was decided in the
Electoral College by 77 000 votes in
three states
and a very surprising outcome that
nobody expected and so in 2018 then lots
of people are like oh man you know
I better participate and they're
reacting to the change in the
conversation to these identity based
issues and then again in 2022
in 2020 it's you know these everyone
knows the election's going to be close
it was closer than 2016. 44 000 votes
across three states determine the 2020
presidential election and so that gets
us a boost in turnout in 2022. so I
think it's not just one issue makes
people go vote it's this sense of
um there's a lot at stake and man these
elections are really close and my vote
might really matter yeah and also on
this one I have a a a very empirical
answer because we have it on the voter
file the the first thing is that this
election will have very few non-voters
coming out there are good there are very
few folks who decided that 20 wasn't
important enough but this one was
um but in 18 the Big Boost was really
among uh one of the big hidden ones that
you can't see without a voter file is
20 presidential Democratic voters who
decided damn this is a midterm I need to
vote in so it wasn't so much people
coming out of nowhere and deciding to
vote it was people who had actually been
pretty regular presidential year voters
deciding in all of the hot house
anti-trump stuff that they better come
out and vote in 2018 as well
just a one other observation that
although the individual issues might
affect a lot of the interelection swings
in terms of just this being a much more
High turnout era that also goes back to
the party's rediscovering get out the
vote and suddenly being in the early
2000s of the Republicans 24 7 project
and then proceeding there's just been a
lot more mobilization effort in the last
two decades than there was in a couple
decades earlier
there you go
um okay uh here's any more observations
on on that before we move on
okay
um
here's another here's a question a year
ago David Brooks observed that the issue
dividing the parties was shifting from
Pro versus Khan the role of government
that has dominated politics since the
New Deal
to America First versus globalism
do you see any evidence that this is
occurring
but so
um your linear on mute
sorry it's my first Zoom
um
sound sounds a lot like calcification to
me not exactly the same idea but this
idea that there's a shifting away from
this new deal Dimension onto something
else
you you mentioned the idea that I'm
sorry Josh why don't you go and then I
had a follow-up Berlin yeah I don't know
if if like Brooks's characterization of
globalism is right for the current
Dimension I mean we see on free trade
that Joe Biden for example is very much
continuing Donald Trey Donald Trump's
anti-free trade policies and on the
inflation reduction act Joe Biden was
very much focused on building America
subsidize American production and
American first kind of manufacturing
policy so
while there might be some of this shift
away from New Deal I don't know if the
dimension is American first versus
globalism
also I do Wonder Lynn what we'll see in
the next two years with Republicans as
they control the house whether or not
they bring back a focus on new deal
issues on tax cuts and ObamaCare like
what is a Kevin McCarthy house going to
look like when it comes to spending
bills
for their thoughts
okay
um let's see
[Music]
okay according to election exit polls
Trump was more of a factor in former
presidents usually are
carries a strong negative net negative
uh was he and his codery of election
deniers the determining element in the
close election and therefore the
partisan divide in both houses
thank you any case sort of yeah we heard
a little about that I think in the
various presentations please uh Lynn
well I was just gonna say like don't
just I mean not every election is close
but in the ones that are close enough
for something like the legacy of trump
to make a difference anything is making
a difference right so like don't try to
not think of
um it's one thing it gets all of these
things
um you know not in every race but in the
ones where you think one thing could
have made the difference it's not just
one thing it's going to be a lot of
these things
okay further further thoughts on that
um
okay
um so uh what here's another question
what influence will voters suppression
uh measures have on the 2024 election do
you think that will be an important fact
well so I think that uh I mean it
depends on what you're going to Define
as voter suppression and sort of I think
that one of the problems with the way we
study
um the anti-voting anti-democracy laws
is we look at um like will this one
provision change this thing rather than
what the accumulation of Shelby Citizens
United bronwitch rucho and everything
else has done to change
in an unrecognizable way the way
elections happen in the United States
right and the the the one to the point
right to go back to the idea of like
this there's an Insurrection and no one
even thinks well will they be held
accountable at the polling places
considered that of the uh 90
um Republicans who ran who voted against
the Electoral College and were running
in states where
um Republicans drew the districts only
one was not in a safe seat
right voters never got a chance to hold
accountable them for this and there's a
way in which the sort of public
discussion is well it must be fair
because neither party has an advantage
but democracy and voters don't have an
advantage if we don't get to actually
exercise a choice in elections
especially after such a momentous event
right and that doesn't get measured in
like a difference a different study on
this voter provision right but the in
the Aggregates we actually just saw such
a paper Josh and I just passed a paper
this very uh very day
but but the point is that like there's
there's stuff that that like you can
just see from outer space right and in
terms of how American elections have
changed and it's and it is it is the
foundation for why we have you know a
Maga House Representatives
good um let me ask one last question
because we're getting close to the end
of our time
um this is a question this program is
great and I would love to get beyond
what I read in the Press would the
panelists give us a few academic papers
to pull and read and let me just say
also maybe a a recommendation for a
website or or places to go
um for commentary and news that they
would recommend as
um as especially insightful and maybe a
different voice than than you would hear
um and get that would allow you to get
beyond what I read in in the Press I
guess I guess it is of course the press
and what I but it's a certain you know
what I mean okay any ideas friends
paper n by side to sonovision fabric
recently came out by Princeton
University press and it was a fantastic
book as well as thank you Josh no is
unstable majority is your most recent
book am I getting that one right uh yes
so The Bitter End and unstable majority
is by two of our panelists are fantastic
books to read
well thank you Josh thank you if you
want commentary on day-to-day politics
um I mentioned research here is the
liberal Patriot there are several
readers or several writers but he he is
particularly good on just an analysis
sort of in between the academic
political science and journalism and um
you know I just think I I will get it
every time he writes something
please
I was just going to say I asked my
graduate students in our last meeting
um this this quarter what the the best
thing was that they read
um all quarter long and then they made
me participate as well and um so I'm
going to share with you the paper that I
read it that I read this quarter so it
does that doesn't mean it just came out
but it's when I read it
um is a paper actually by
um some Yale folks
um I I don't know how to say This
Woman's first name I think it is it Lila
or Lila or
um o r r and our friend and your
colleague Greg Huber
um and this is a paper that is in um I
think it's in the American Political
Science review and it is about sorting
out how much of people's reactions to
the parties are purely based on emotion
and how much of it has a policy
component to it
um and and it's not a mystery novel so
I'll just give away the finding is that
a good deal of people's reactions
emotional reactions to the party or to
People's Party labels comes from the
beliefs about what they want to do in
the world so we hear you know oh like I
don't want my son or daughter to marry a
Republican or marry a Democrat ah in its
emotion but what they sort out is that
actually a lot of that is because you
wouldn't want your child to marry
someone who holds those beliefs and it
isn't just emotional it's a really
really creative and nice paper
I'll give another answer as well which
is
re read political science journals so I
mean some of our journals are the
American Political Science review the
American Journal of political science
look at the abstracts look at the table
of contents don't pay for the articles
but if you see an article that really
interests you email the author and those
authors are always happy to send those
PDFs to folks so if you see a paper that
interests you feel free to reach out
um don't send long rambly emails to
academics but if you want like a little
PDF we're more than happy
yes
right so so I think we're going to see a
run on the American political I was just
going to say I I already sent a field
experiment from uh from
from a political scientists to see if
they'll send PDFs to people
okay
who's more likely to respond yeah well
I'm sure that's I'm some version of that
has been done and many times I I guess I
assume by all sorts of people including
graduate students and uh and
undergraduates so um all very good uh
Mike do you have anything you want to
recommend uh uh oh I don't think so no
no I'd love uh not just The Bitter End
but the books before it I think they're
the best volume Recaps of all of the
things and I think one of the things
that I think is really great about them
is that uh you
um it's the way you take different
topics that are were of interest during
the election and find a way to explore
them in a smart database way
um which usually is never the case when
they're discussed in public and and so I
thought those were really good
great thank you terrific I did think of
a I thought of a podcast I thought just
my favorite political podcast is
um hacks on tap which is David Axelrod
and Mike Murphy and they are not doing
policy but they are talking about
elections and strategy and the kinds of
things that campaign Consultants talk
about
um and so if you like that kind of thing
which it sounds like from the Q a people
sort of do
um I I recommend it it's it's funny and
it's all it's weekly and um super
relevant yeah actually I'll do one other
thing but which is just category more of
a category that that I think is really
under appreciated is but the what I've
seen in new attempts to
have uh analysis of political economy
where it's not just about one more
person doing or on surveys but really
understanding things like path
dependency in our country and the
different ways economic interests all
those kinds of things and as kind of an
old guy right like that's used to be the
way people understood things and uh I
think if it's making a comeback that's a
great thing
great well thank you um thank you all
um uh we're coming I guess to the end of
our time I want to thank everyone for
attending tonight's session and for the
excellent questions I'm very grateful to
all the panelists for their thoughtful
uh uh thoughtful contributions to our
conversation today
um again Mophie Arena Josh Cala my
thought house of horror and Lynn fabric
uh thank you again for contributing your
time to this event I also want to once
again thank my colleagues at isps uh Pam
green Rick Harrison LaMore pier and Kara
wishart who um who worked to help get
this event put together today I'm very
grateful to all they do to further the
isps mission of research and teaching
and then I I finally want to mention
that um we're going to do this again in
a week
the second elections panel
um because there's so much more to think
about and reflect on and so you'll um
for those of you on our mailing list
you'll be receiving additional
information about that uh soon and I
also want to welcome you to visit the
isps website where we post information
about all of our events again uh thank
you all very much and I wish you a happy
holidays and a wonderful evening good
night
thank you